eonia quelqu'un n'importe qui je suis
enfermé dans la peau d'un chat faut que
quelqu'un m'aide
j'avoue là avec votre horrible veste
verte alors est-ce que savannah temps le
cauchemar continue au notre monde
non tu ne rêves pas vous chers je suis
l'homme qui murmure à l'oreille des
chats et je suis le seul à pouvoir
entendre
qu'est ce que vous m'avez fait je n'ai
rien fait du tout tu es tombé d'un toit
bien comment je sors de sa mauvaise
question
la bonne c'est comment je suis entré
notion bien comment je suis rentré dans
sa c'est à toi de trouver l'explication
et il vaudrait mieux tu arrives
ça veut dire qu à ça donc on n'est pas
éternel et s'il vient d'expirer tu
restera coincé dans celui ci pour
l'instant tout à fait moi sortir de la
maison nous monsieur brand vous êtes un
chat ça n'a rien de dramatique mais je
déteste ça c'est bien pour ça que c'est
parfait